this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
you
I'm Jamie Beckett and I'm Director of
Communications and alumni relations here
at the School of Engineering and I'm
happy to welcome you tonight to the
latest in our career lecture series when
we help you advance your career and
offer networking opportunities with
fellow engineering alumni next up in
this series is the engineering job fair
that's coming up this fall but much
sooner than that there's a very special
and very different kind of event we'll
be honoring professor emeritus donald
knuth
that's on may 12th as you probably know
he's author of the seminal work the art
of computer programming a professor
Knuth will be inducted as one of our
Stanford engineering heroes it's a
brand-new program and that's May 12th we
hope you'll be able to join us then
tonight however I'm delighted to
introduce professor Robert Sutton as you
know he's probably he's a professor of
management science and engineering he's
much published and he studies innovation
leaders and civilized work for
workplaces something I think we all
probably are interested in Bob's written
five books including the New York Times
bestseller the no rule building
a civilized workplace and surviving one
that isn't tonight however he'll be
sharing his insights from his latest
book good boss bad boss how to be the
best and learn from the worst we'll be
hearing from Bob in just a minute and
after tonight if you want to follow him
you can follow his blog at Bob Sutton
dotnet or follow him on twitter at work
underscore Mathers we'll have time for
questions at the end and I hope you'll
be able to stay afterward for networking
and refreshments thanks and now
professor Sutton
better wait till after the speech so
thank you for all coming out tonight I
suspect many of you have been to the
building well how many of you is this
the first time you've been to this
building oh it's a lot of isn't it a
lovely building I especially compared to
the term in building the improvement is
unbelievable so I thought I was gonna
have a life sentence in the term in
building and this it's like being young
again this building is just fabulous so
so what I'm gonna do tonight is take
maybe about 50 minutes or so and talk
about some of the main ideas and in my
latest book good boss bad boss and at
the end we'll have a little twist sort
of some stuff from the no rule
on how to deal with a lousy boss at the
request of the Alumni Association which
I I don't think is a reflection on
anybody but especially Dean Plummer
who's a wonderful guy so that's what I'm
gonna do and let me sort of start out
and describe how I ended up writing this
book because um I didn't exactly mean to
start out writing a book on bosses
although and although I've studied
management in various forms for quite a
few years as was mentioned the book I
wrote before this was the no
rule and one of the good and bad things
about writing a best-seller is it sort
of like Hollywood they always want the
sequel so I was actually under all this
pressure to write a sequel to that book
and at one point I said well maybe I
really should do it so I started working
on it and and I just kind of didn't have
it in me and I think maybe this sort of
final blow was I got um a postcard you
know nobody sends postcard anywhere it
was like a handwritten postcard from my
publisher in France and she asked the
question she said dear Bob when do we
see the shit's again was what be
it actually may have said strikes but I
should probably my blog it sure looked
like the SH word to me so at that point
I realized that although I may be
condemned to being the guy the
rest of my life I did not have another
book on the topic in me so I started
thinking about it and looking at this
sort of like the deluge of emails the
stories that I got that people told me
and I realized something which I knew
before but it really became more vivid
that the central character is in most of
the stories people told me about 80% of
the stories they told me were the boss
so in most cases frankly they worked for
a boss was a jerk because that's what I
the kind of stories people tell me in
some cases people told me how great
their boss was and then in a lot of
other cases people would describe to me
how they wanted to be in general better
bosses and so I started digging into
research on management and leadership
and and the reason that I picked the
word boss in a focus on boss rather than
management in general is that um if you
look at what it takes to have an
effective organization overall there's
actually a lot of evidence that it isn't
just the boss at the top it's the
overall quality of the bosses in the
organization there's also evidence even
if you look at the way that CEOs have
impact on their organizations it's not
like they just magically have an effect
it's it's it comes through the quality
of the team that they build around them
so even when it comes to the CEO it's
their immediate team that really seems
to matter so so that what and then one
other point which turns out to be true
the notion that people leave Morgana's
to leave bosses not organizations which
is a truism actually turns out to be
true so I was off and since I have the
privilege of working this university I
had time to work on the book and I spent
several years working on the book and so
what I'm gonna do is describe some of
the main ideas tonight but before I do I
want to sort of give this a little bit
sort of a background or perspective of
of how I wrote this book and how I
actually write most of my books but
first of all I want to ask a question
how many of you have heard of Jimmy
Buffett
okay you're laughing but there's not all
the hands went up so just as as a
Generation Y test so I gave a version of
this talk at Facebook which is sort of
like the Children's Crusade anybody in
engineering Wow and there's some pretty
damn smart children there by the way and
maybe 15% of them had heard of Jimmy
Buffett so so doubt it
so so if you want to feel old that
that's how I felt anyways so in one of
his songs he's got this line that some
things are still a mystery to me and
other things are much too clear and sort
of following this philosophy the way
that I wrote this book and I wrote my
other books as well with often with
co-authors with Jeff Pfeffer in
particular is what I would do would be
to read the peer-reviewed literature
because this is I'm still at a research
university and I actually believe in
evidence-based management and and when I
soft sort of a pattern what I would do
is sort of make an assertion and there's
some ideas you hear about tonight and
and then since I know research can be
pretty boring I usually dig out or find
some stories to actually make the
evidence come to life but there were a
bunch of cases where I would think that
I could find a pattern but I'd sort of
give up and let me give you one example
so how many of you in organizations
where they have performance evaluations
yeah I am - okay so the literature on
performance evaluation is pretty
interesting if performance evaluations
were like a drug they would not get FDA
approval it's sort of like if you look
at some reasonable meta analyses we have
lately about 40% of the time they makes
time they make things better
40% worse than 20% sort of no effect so
that's I didn't talk very much about
performance evaluations even though it's
really interesting just about every
company I know in the valley is sort of
an obsessed with how to do these things
right and there are some organizations
that do it better than others but boy
that's a tough thing to deal with
so so most of the stuff in the book are
at least things that I believe based on
reading the research that there's kind
of a pattern there okay so now let's
move to the main point of the book
there's lots of little point
in the book but if I were to pick sort
of a central theme and the thread that
runs through much of it it's this notion
that sort of runs contrary in some ways
to common wisdom which is this notion
that great bosses are remarkably
obsessed self-obsessed if there's a an
expression you've probably heard before
that when you're the boss it's not about
you which is probably it's it's like a
useful half truth and certainly in S
we'll get into this I'm not making the
case that bosses should be raging
narcissist or egomaniac that's exactly
the opposite of the case I'm gonna make
but the fact is if you look at it from
an empirical standpoint there's an
enormous ly bright light that shines on
people when they're in positions of
authority and actually gets brighter as
they get higher in two ways in which
this gets played out one I talk about a
fair amount in the second chapter and
the other one kind of runs through the
book the first one is that when you're
in a position of leading other people
your lot in life is that you are gonna
get more blame and more credit than you
deserve for the performance of the
people in the organization you leave and
and this is just if you don't want the
situation don't become a boss or
especially a CEO this is what's going to
happen in in the academics have looked
at all sorts of different conditions
under which leadership matters and
doesn't if I was going to give you my
rough approximation and some of my
colleagues would probably disagree with
me especially on the first one
on average bosses are worth maybe 10
maybe 20 percent of the action in
performance some of my colleagues would
say less including some Nobel Prize
winners but one thing that academics
don't disagree about is basically they
get about 50% of the bread of the credit
and blame for performance so that's the
first way if you lead others that you're
gonna get more credit and more blame
than you deserve and part of your job is
to handle some of the symbolic stuff
around credit and blame independently of
whether or not stuff is your fault or
not so that's the first point about it
sort of is is about you in the second
point is this notion that that when when
people are in a position of authority
there's sis notion of they called
asymmetrical attention sometime and the
social
psychology literature which is the
notion that subordinates people have
less power to vote a lot more attention
to what their boss does then then their
boss to votes to them and in and so that
the reason that this creates a challenge
is that there's a lot of evidence that
the best bosses are in tune with the
people they lead they know what it feels
like to work for them but there's
something about being in a position of
authority and maybe we could talk about
what it is that that that that puts you
in a position where you pay less
attention and sometimes this creates
what I've called the toxic tandem and
what the toxic tandem is is it is a
situation where they know a whole bunch
about you and you don't know much about
them and you get in trouble and let me
give you an example in it's sort of an
interesting case so many of us will
remember in it wasn't much fun things
are much better around here from what I
can tell in most cases that in early
2009 all around the valley in particular
in the country there was layoffs and
organizations and hopefully that's
starting to come back a little bit now
so around that time I was finishing up
this book and I pulled over and wrote an
article for the Harvard Business Review
I'm called how to be a good boss in a
bad economy it's about dealing with
downsizing in other sorts of situations
especially how to be compassionate about
it and so I gave a talk it was one of
our executive programs and afterwards
one of the executives walked up to me
and he said let me tell you a story
about what happened in our office last
week which was one of the assistants she
walked up to an executive vice president
and said to him when of the layoffs
coming and he was like completely
shocked because it was one of those sort
of well hidden layoffs nobody knew was
coming but it and so he admitted he said
yes in about two weeks we're going to
have a fairly large-scale layoffs and
then he said to her how did you know and
her answer was well it was an
interesting shoes day for you
so what this guy had was he had sort of
a towel or a leakage thing if you read
that some other think where when he
something bad was gonna happen he would
look at his shoes rather than look
people in the eye and it's in the
interesting thing about that is being a
toxic tandem is he didn't know that he
had an interesting shoes problem but
everybody who worked for him did and
that's sort of the classic the classic
sort of indication that they're watching
you real closely it's already talked
about the toxic tandem another example
this is Linda Hudson who's now CEO of EA
systems when she became president of
another large defense contractor
actually she tells the story this was in
the New York Times about how she went to
Nordstrom so she got her new job as
president bought some new clothes
including a new scarf and so she bought
some scarves and the salesperson at
Nordstrom showed her how to tie the
scarf in sort of a special interesting
way and she noticed with by the end of
the week of her first week there was
about ten other women in the office
tying their scarves to the exact same
way and that but you know she noticed it
and as the quote says this is the
problem that leaders have is there's an
incredibly bright spotlight on them this
is something that apparently is part of
our animal heritage so the typical
member of a baboon troop glances up at
the alpha male every 20 or 30 seconds so
it isn't just us apparently this is
something that's wired in and it sort of
makes sense from the standpoint of this
is the person or in this case the ape
who can do good or bad things for us
because they have more power than we do
so it does make some have some survival
value but one of the reasons it's so
hard for people to be in tune with the
people they lead is something that that
I call power poisoning there's other
names for it in the academic literature
so now we've got at least a good 200
studies that in some ways can be
actually kind of discouraging because
they show independently a personality
when you give people power over others a
whole bunch of things happen which are
not particularly good news three of the
main ones is when you give people power
they tend to focus more on their own
needs and concerns they tend to focus
less attention on the needs and actions
of others and they also act like the
rules don't apply to them
so this is something that that that
we're all as human beings have to fight
and happens to us and just to show you
my favorite study that shows how that
this can happen this isn't the most
rigorous study but it's the cutest so
cute so of course very important so this
was done at my alma mater although they
don't like when I say this here UC
Berkeley and it this was done about
about seven or eight years ago and it's
reported by Deb grünfeld who's at the
business school here in dr. Keltner at
Berkeley and the basic set up was they
had three Berkeley students
brainstorming about how to solve a
social problem so things like how do you
make the UC Berkeley campus more green
things like that and but the real
manipulation since there psychologists
and psychologists just about always lied
to their subjects what was really going
on the real manipulation was about half
way through the little brainstorm they
brought in a plate of five cookies so
the question is and we all know the norm
you don't eat the last cookie what
happens to cookie number four and the
one thing I didn't add which is really
important is two of them were brainstorm
and one was assigned randomly assigned
is the boss to evaluate the quality of
the ideas so you've got this power
difference so what happened was if the
people in power tended to take the
fourth cookie and it gets better there
was a three item measure of disinhibited
eating they tended to eat with their
mouths open this is independently coded
and leave more crumbs okay also
independently assess because they were
separate little tables so so so if you
go back to this is really cute but go
back to sort of like the three findings
more focused on my own needs and concern
it's less than the needs of others and
acting like the rules don't apply to me
there really is a risk for anybody who
has authority over others that they're
gonna sort of have this just in the
disinhibition problem one thing I should
probably say at this point before we
start getting the principles cuz I'm
talking about all these risks of being
an authority is that yes just about all
people and authority are of risk of
having this happen
that's the bad news
the good news is that it turns out we've
actually got some pretty good national
surveys lately that despite the
challenges that bosses face maybe it
depends on the server you look at
seventy seventy five percent of
Americans will still report that their
bosses are competent caring so it's not
like all the bosses out there are
complete losers and are destructive but
the fact is and I think this is
important that there are certain
tendencies that anybody's in the
position of authority has to fight and I
would argue that those of us who are led
by others have some responsibility to
help them see the light and we'll talk
about that a little bit at the end okay
so so what I want to do next is to start
digging into some hallmarks of Intune
bosses so these are sort of some of the
ideas floating around the book one of
the first one which I talked about in
the first chapter at least start with
this one of assertiveness so if you read
the management literature like I think
the best-selling book in the last 15 or
20 years is good - great
by a guy named Jim Collins there'll be a
lot of discussion about the importance
of charisma and it turns out although
Jim Collins was very hard on charisma
that people who are charismatic but not
selfish or narcissistic probably are
more effective leaders but one of the
interesting things that comes from these
studies on assertiveness by Frank Flynn
and another guy named Daniel Ames is
that it turns out at least in the
research that the the level of
assertiveness of the bosses was probably
more important than charisma and and
what they found in a series of surveys
it asked people to rate their bosses and
things like would you want to work for
the person again would you want to be
like that boss would you recommend the
boss to a friend how effective do you
think the boss was things like that that
that the main predictor was essentially
that the most effective bosses were sort
of in the middle in terms of
assertiveness so they were moderately
assertive so some of them the measures
they use and the point here is not just
that they were medium pushy all the time
that's not what this research shows
especially once they started digging
into it in fact what the best bosses had
was the ability to read the situation
they were in and the people they led and
they knew when to push
they knew when to back off and I think
that all of us who've had well at least
more than one child or have had more
than one subordinate my case would be
largely doctoral students that there's
some of them who you really need to push
hard and some of them if you push they
just sort of freeze up and you've got to
back off so so that notion of being in
tune with what it feels like to work for
you really does seem to be important
especially when it comes to
assertiveness and as an example although
I'm a San Fran is fan I think Tommy
Lasorda put this quite well the day he
took over the LA Dodgers from his
autobiography I believe managing is like
holding a dove in your hand if you hold
it too tightly you kill it if you hold
it too loosely you lose it so in general
there's this notion of being in tune one
sort of footnote I would add is that
that on average the best bosses know
when to turn it on and off but one time
when bosses tend to get too pushy in
particular is when they're leading
innovative or creative work and overall
just on the sort of pushiness to go back
to the pushing this thing
there's an interesting body of research
some of it reported by my are done by my
colleague Jeff Pfeffer which shows that
it's kind of interesting it shows how
boss has become micro managers and why
they believe it works so what they show
is that the more closely a boss watches
a subordinate the more input they give
them the more questions they ask the
more highly they rate the quality of the
work done by that person independently
of a subjective quality so what that
means is if you watch somebody coach
them you're going to think I put all
this effort into this of course they're
doing better work but it's just a
cognitive illusion and in fact where
this gets really bad is when it comes to
creative work where if people start
being evaluated and watched closely they
start worried about they worry about
screwing up in front of the boss so they
go back to the tried and true and we
actually become less creative so to this
point one of my favorite quotes this is
probably about eight years ago I did a
panel with this guy bill coin who led
R&D at 3m for over a decade and his
comment was after you play
the seed in the ground you don't dig it
up every week to see how it's doing and
with information technology I think that
some bosses can dig it up like every
nine seconds you know they can t send
you an email they want and I gave a talk
yesterday where no earlier in the week
and I better not say the exact location
but they were doing tweets and I kept
having a guy in the front row tell me
how I was doing in mid talk it's like I
don't want to know actually so so I even
experienced that this week one other
thing about Bill coin that was sort of
interesting is he described his role of
how to buy R&D at 3m was largely keeping
senior management away from his people
was that I thought was actually sort of
interesting okay the second thing that's
a hallmark of good bosses is wisdom and
this is a topic that my colleague Jeff
Pfeffer and I have well we've talked
about in probably two other previous
books and then I talked about a good
boss bad boss the first time I got
interested in wisdom as a concept in
fact was inspired by another Stanford
engineering faculty member David Kelly
of IDEO Fame and one of my doctoral
students Andy hargadon and I were doing
an ethnography at idea when we watch
David Kelly in action and he really
isn't an incredible guy he's also the
founder of the d.school for those of you
don't know just an amazing force in the
world of innovation and that's where we
first got interested in this notion of
wisdom and to sort of back off on wisdom
it's sort of interesting when you look
at somebody like David Kelly in action
they have this ability to be confident
enough that that that they're secure in
their ideas but they somehow or another
have enough self-doubt and humility to
become to avoid becoming arrogant jerks
and in the way that this plays out and
we really saw this in action at IDEO and
you can see it in the d.school
when we're at our best - which is that
people have the attitude of wisdom have
the courage to act on what they know but
they also have enough humility to
question their assumptions and actions
it's sort of like this balancing act
between if you will a sort of
self-confidence in some humility and to
give you sort of a good definition of
this the famous Andy Grove of Intel Fame
put this quite well I think it's very
important for you to do two things act
on your temporary conviction as if it's
a real conviction and when you realize
you're wrong correct course very quickly
sounds really easy it's incredibly
difficult to do you've got to be very
much aware of the impact of what's going
on around you so you've actually got to
listen to the people around you so this
is a great quote about from John Wooden
the basketball most famous basketball
coach probably in history don't act as
if you're listening and let it go in one
ear and out the other it's even worse to
actually fake you know faking it is even
worse than not doing it at all
it sounds easy but very often when
executives go to meeting after meeting
they often will get into the mode of
pretending to listen but not really
listening there was actually one company
my colleague huggy Rao and I huggies at
the Business School we worked with him
about three years ago if there was this
one boss I'll never forget one of those
kind of guys who was just talked and
talked and talked and talked and talked
and talked and talked and would never
actually listen and and we're in a
meeting and there was this moment where
he actually shut up and he sat down and
appointed somebody else to stand up and
do the talking and he looks at me and he
says he said it looks like I'm listening
but I'm not really listening I'm just
reloading thinking about what I'm gonna
say next he was sort of like the classic
like dysfunctional boss and and one
thing I will say by the way in you think
of people like that and large American
corporations be able to get away with it
this guy is we worked with them long
enough he actually got in quite a bit of
trouble and got kind of pushed aside and
the main reason was he in their words as
he was all transmission and no reception
so so is somebody who actually got in
trouble for it even worse than not
listening is creating a climate of fear
if you're a boss and people are afraid
to give you bad news and if you
criticize them demote them or humiliate
them you're not going to hear it a great
example of this is although it is unfair
to blame any one person for the
financial meltdown that happened a few
years ago if you want to blame somebody
Michael Lewis tells you this is the guy
this is joe cassano it was at AIG he led
the the unit that lost about 45
billion dollars which all of us US
taxpayers are now still bailing out as I
understand it and and so Michael Lewis
did a bunch of reporting and I love this
part in particular the way you dealt
with Jo was to start everything by
saying you're right Jo
so certainly fear is bad but one thing I
always like to point out in in many of
you who are managers who have managers
as well too may not be in a fear Laden
situation but even then there's a lot of
challenges to creating a situation where
people feel safe telling you the truth
because there's a bunch of things going
on in hierarchical like life that are
very difficult to to avoid and let me
give you two of them sort of the
positive and the negative the positive
is there's actually a lot of evidence
that when people say nice things to us
and flatter us even false flattery even
we know they're just biessing us we
still like them more so if you just
think of hierarchical life there's all
sorts of incentive for people to tell
you how good you look how wonderful you
are and the story I always tell about
this I've got a colleague rod Cramer rod
and I came to Stanford more or less the
same time I see rod about once a year
and whenever I see him he just about
always says the same thing to me which
is Bob you look good you look like you
lost weight and first of all I almost
never have lost weight by the way um
second of all I always say to myself
he's just saying that but then it makes
me like rod more and and so we as human
beings we've got to be it and if you're
in a position of authority there's all
these people have an incentive and they
may not realize it and you may not even
realize it then on the other side and
this or the mom effect slide comes in
there's there's another pretty big body
of research that shows that even when um
when people give us bad news that's not
their fault we like them less this is
the sort of shoot the messenger problem
and so that's the other problem is that
that that they'll be some bad news
floating around and nobody will tell the
boss because they don't want the boss to
have that negative emotional reaction
and in the hierarchal life this is one
of the things that leads to filtering
in one of the best examples I know of
this this is the famous late Richard
Fineman certainly one of the most
entertaining physicists and Nobel Prize
winners who ever lived and part of his
amazing legacy is he was appointed he
was appointed to the Rogers Commission
to help figure out why the Challenger
Space Shuttle blew up and and he went
rogue and Rogers actually got quite mad
at him because he ran around NASA asking
questions in an unauthorized way and one
of the questions he asked an amazing
sort of if you know the story like he he
had this demonstration in front of
Congress and he figured out the seals
just incredible guy but he also asked
this hypothetical question about
something that still has not happened I
guess we've got two more missions
hopefully it won't happen he asked
people to estimate the probability that
the main shuttle engine would fail and
sort of look at this the engineers
estimated one in 200 odds the senior
executives one in a hundred thousand and
some of that might have been some PRBS
but but some that also is the sort of
filtering and if you know if you know
that case that stuff does not get up the
hierarchy and so so even if you're the
nicest most benevolent boss the world
you've got to be careful because there's
situations where people are going to be
afraid to tell you the truth because
very often in this sort of unconscious
way it's in their best interest not to
so one of the things that organizations
do to help sort of encourage an attitude
of wisdom is to create situations where
people can fight in an atmosphere of
mutual respect it's one of the hallmarks
of organizations that overcome this this
problem especially a good engineering
organization people fight over ideas and
and I guess I should emphasize that I'm
not saying that that you should have
fights with people because you hate one
another that's like really a bad sort of
conflict I'm talking about fighting in
an atmosphere of mutual respect
so situations where people fight as if
they are right and listen as if they are
wrong having taught at Stanford for 26
or 27 years I keep losing count our
undergraduates in particular how many of
you were undergraduate so I'm gonna get
in trouble with this are really good at
fighting as if they're right but the
listing is if the wrong part is
sometimes a problem because you're all
so smart and and so what the best bosses
do is they make it stick
safe to fight in an atmosphere of mutual
respect William Wrigley put this quite
well when two people in business always
agree one of them is unnecessary so it's
kind of cute probably the most
interesting person who at least I've
interviewed in this in this domain and
this account is Brad Bird a Pixar Brad
as the Academy award-winning director of
ratatouille and of The Incredibles and
it's sort of an interesting story what
happened with Brad Bird is he was
brought into Pixar
by Steve Jobs Edie Catmull and John
Lasseter after they had had three hit
movies and in unlike many organizations
they were worried that they were gonna
get a success trap and start believing
their own BS too much which I think
really speaks well for the senior
management team they brought in Brad who
had been fired by all sorts of people
for being overly obsessed well what he's
really obsessed with getting to know him
a little bit is the notion of mediocrity
is just enough not to him I mean he
really really is one of those people
always pushes for excellence that's why
I got fired at Disney was for giving
them brief about how mediocre they were
and also apparently why I got fired by
The Simpsons as well The Simpsons has
kind of gotten worse by the way so
anyhow so he was brought in and his job
was to shake things up
and when we interviewed him he said the
first thing I did this was to make the
Incredibles he said I went to the people
in HR and I said he said I want your
black sheep I want the people who are
ready to quit Pixar think who think that
everything Pixar is doing is wrong and
this is like one of the most successful
companies we have and so he was brought
in to sort of stir things up in his
motto and this is from the Iron Giant of
film he did before is everyone will get
humiliated and encouraged together so I
think it's sort of a cute way to put it
so that's an argument for fighting two
other things about fighting arguing that
creative groups fight and good leaders
create fighting you shouldn't fight when
you're generating new ideas at the very
very early stage you kind of want to get
the ideas on the table before you start
ripping them apart and then also and
this is another thing I'm thinking of
all the creative teams I've taught at
the Stanford d.school there comes a
point where when their idea gets killed
off that they think is so great they
keep
trying to push it back into the mix
there's a point where you've kind of got
to shut up and help with the
implementation of what's going on so I'm
not arguing for fighting all the time
the second the third thing which is a
quick thing is there's a whole bunch of
books coming out that are talking about
small wins there's a book a little bit
bets that just came out and there's a
woman at Harvard called
Teresa Amabile is something on small
wins so small wins or all of a sudden
very hot but the small wins stuff is
interesting because what it shows is
that although the most effective bosses
and organizations will create these big
hairy goals that people can get behind
and get excited about is that if you
just have the goals and don't show the
stepping stones that people need to take
they freaked out they freeze up and it
they literally can't act so so when
you're a boss it's it's your
responsibility to help people figure out
those stepping stones and to give you a
good example there's one CEO I know I've
worked with a little bit and she
described to me how and again this is
early 2009 when it wasn't much fun
around here and she presented to her
team a goal that if they didn't have
their most successful sales campaign in
history that they'd have to do a quite
large scale layoff so so she says she
sort of describes me so I I tell him
that that's our goal it's like a 25%
increase over the year before and she
said they all started yelling at me they
started freaking out and she said she
realized he kind of made a mistake
because what she did was she's sort of
calm down and she passed out the yellow
sticky notes I don't know where they
were yellow actually but they were
sticky notes and she asked them to write
on the sticky notes all the steps they
would need to take this is her senior
team for it to be a successful sales
campaign and pretty soon they had more
than 100 sticky notes and she did this
really cool thing so the sticky notes
are the little steps they need to take
but then she drew a line on the board
and put she wrote easy and hard and they
put the easy ones up in the hard one and
she said they worked just the next week
just on accomplishing the easy ones to
get some traction and some encouragement
and to me that's a pretty good example
of the initial problem of people
freaking out and then breaking it into
small wins with the added twist of the
low-hanging
fruit so I thought that was actually
pretty cool okay two more points and
then I've got a couple of wrap-up points
so we'll probably and maybe 2022 after
this just a rough guess and then we can
it because I won't have some comments
one other point which which I got quite
interested in writing this book well
once an old theme and the other ones a
newer one is this notion of stars in
rotten apples so let me start out with
the stars so um one of the things this
goes back to a lot of work that Jeff
Pfeffer and I have done is that in the
in the process of thinking about
organizations that are good at sort of
fostering cooperative work one of the
things we see over and over again is the
question that we tend to ask is who are
you making your super stars are they
people who get ahead by stomping on
others on the way to the top or are they
people who help the others around them
succeed and it's pretty simple but
there's all sorts of organizations that
have much different reward systems and
performance evaluation systems to use
that word and the ones that tend to
reward that the the team players tend to
be better at collaborative work in
particular and the reason I've got the
Men's Warehouse example is that I'm long
ago this is like 1997 or something when
Jeff Pfeffer and I were writing one of
our book my first management book the
knowing doing gap Jeff attended suits
University so it was sort of ran by you
know the Men's Warehouse the off sale
sort of or the the wholesale men's
clothing place and when he went to Men's
Warehouse George Zimmer the George
Zimmer the guy you see on TV who says I
guarantee it told a story about their
Seattle store and what happened at their
Seattle store was they had a problem
where they had a guy who kept
undermining what they call the team
selling environment so the way it works
when you walk into a Men's Warehouse is
there's one person is getting the
Commission but the other folks in the
store are supposed to help it be sort of
like a team experience and that's how
it's supposed to feel but this guy was
their top salesperson in the
northwestern area and he kept stealing
sales from other folks
at mouthing the team selling concept and
so what they did was they fired him
which is you know the classic sort of
superstar salesman problem salesperson
problem but the interesting thing was
after they got rid of him although no
individual salesperson reached his level
of stardom sales went up about 30
percent in the store so it's sort of
like a good indication of how toxic a
person can be so this brings us to the
notion of how how toxic sort of bad
selfish negative people can be and to
sort of oversimplify it if if you sort
of ask what's more important for a boss
to eliminate the negative or accentuate
the positive there's a pretty big body
of research and if somebody if you want
to send me an email I'll send you the
seminal paper which is called bad is
stronger than good which shows that that
what ends up happening is that whether
we're talking about work relationships
or we're talking about personal
relationships that bad interactions with
people pack much larger wallets than
than big ones so in the workplace is a
situation where if you have a bad
encounter with somebody at work an
unpleasant one it packs five times the
effect on mood then a good one and then
we move to personal relationships and
this is more important than the work
stuff for those of us are trying to
maintain personal relationships it turns
out marriages dating relationships and
so on when you go below five to one so
for every bad interaction you have you
don't have at least five good ones the
relationships tend to fall apart so I've
been married a long time like forever it
seems like 26 or 27 years I'm kind of
forgetting actually at this point and
and I sort of tell myself that when I've
been bad that I have to do five good
things to make up for what I've done so
that's the rule I follow and and this
sort of brings us to the notion of teams
in the toxic miss of sort of negative
destructive people and there's this
great article and there's even a This
American Life episode on this article
it's unusual for an academic article
some of you may have heard by will
Phelps and others and essentially what
they show across a bunch of studies is
that if you've just got one rotten apple
in your group
one person who is well I would call them
an
somebody who is like a deadbeat doesn't
work hard enough somebody who's really
depressive that the overall performance
of the team goes down thirty or forty
percent in Phelps argues that there's
two main reasons this happens the first
is that when you've got a rotten apple
on your team what happens is you end up
devoting too much attention to dealing
with the rotten apple and not enough
attention to the performance issues and
then the other reason the performance
goes down is that there's a fair amount
of evidence that negative emotions are
especially contagious so you literally
catch the disease from them so that's an
argument you should get rid of them and
to give you one example of sort of my
favorite story about a rotten apple
after I published the no rule so
I was reading Fortune magazine you know
I have 70 AC unfortunate magazine every
year they come up with the best place to
work survey so I'm reading the best
place to Sir work survey and and there I
think was at number 39 then there's this
company called Baird a financial
services firm and there's a one sentence
description which was they tout they're
no rule so I got all excited
these guys are actually talking about it
they're publishing and Fortune magazine
so pretty quickly I got on the phone
with the sky' Paul Purcell and I talked
to his head of HR too and we talked a
bunch about you know how he enforces it
one of the things he said which was
incredibly entertaining and this is the
quote he says during the interview I
tell them that if I discover they're an
I'm going to fire them he said I
looked them in the eye I've never heard
of the selection technique maybe they we
don't use it at Stanford but but he said
he said that every now and then he said
somebody will turn pale and you'll never
see him again stuff like that but but
the thing that I thought was most
interesting is when I asked him I said
well what do you mean by somebody being
an because if in my book I tend
to describe such people as people who
leave others feeling demeaned and
de-energized but he in some ways I think
had a better answer for organizations
and it kind of goes back to the George
Zimmer definition that he said people
like that are people who consistently
put their own needs ahead of their
colleagues customers in the organ
and I thought that was actually pretty
good and by the way of all financial
services firms would apply this I think
we'd have all be better off but but but
I thought that was a pretty interesting
definition okay one more and then we'll
move to a couple wrap-up points one of
the other chapters and something that I
really got quite obsessed when writing
the book was when you look at the
hallmark of what people will describe as
a good boss the kind of boss they want
to work for in particular it's somebody
who has my back and to you know dig in
just a little bit more basically people
who shield you to the extent that's
reasonable from harm and dignity stupid
little intrusions one of the hallmarks
of good bosses um this could just be
visitors so I love this definition from
Henry Mintzberg
as a manager is somebody who sees
visitors so that other people can get
their work done I can tell you my office
is down the hall from gym plumbers he
sees like a hundred times more visitors
than I do thank goodness I'm glad he's
talking to them and I'm not frankly so
so that's part of like a Deans or other
manager's job
meetings now meetings are one of those
things that in fact my colleague Jeff
Pfeffer and I sometimes argue about this
and so I've written two books with Jeff
and we fight constantly
and Jeff's latest book is called power
and sabar all these ways you can grab
power and show like you're the person in
charge and Jeff will actually advise it
if you really want to get power you'll
do stuff like you'll arrive to meetings
a little late to show that it's so
important the meeting can't start
without you and then the other thing you
would do is keep people longer because
even if there isn't any more work to do
that shows you're more important than
anything else in their life be it work
life or non work life so so and I sort
of say to Jeff that's great if you want
to get power but they actually cared
about the people you work for you might
actually want to end meetings early so
they could get off and do their work and
and and and then it maybe have as few
meetings as possible and so the reason I
have will right here famous sorta game
designer
is he describes this employee centered
method uses during meetings which is he
used to have one one guy Oshin Quigley
the actual person's name who would ocean
Quigley started looking bored and raised
his hand and asked to be excused that
was a sign the meeting should be over so
yeah it's sort of like the canary in the
coalmine guy
and the other thing that will Wright did
was he charged people a doll or whenever
they would call a meeting just to get
them to think about it a little bit by
the way having been at Stanford for a
long time the guy who was most amazing
amazing on meetings was John Hennessy
when he was Dean of the School of
Engineering John hates long meetings and
it was great because we have meetings
with him and he they be scheduled for an
hour at they'd last like nine minutes
and anybody's never dealt with John he
is so decisive he kind of says three
things yes no I'll get back to you later
and I'm talking about major decision so
with John you never had the feeling he
was keeping you too long and you know
John has a lot to do it's kind of cool
the other thing that good bosses do is
they find ways to protect people from
idiocy from on high the fact is that in
many organizations of all sizes or some
idiocy that flows down in my favorite
NEC story happened when I was a new
assistant professor at Stanford it seems
like a thousand years ago but I did a
dissertation on organizational death the
process by which organizations are sort
of unwound after the decision was made
so it's so long ago I was like reading
the San Francisco Chronicle which I
guess I still do although I'm not sure
why and so I was reading the San
Francisco Chronicle and what I'm sorry
used to work at the con I'm sorry there
isn't much left in it anymore I feel
badly but anyways so so anyhow so I was
reading the San Francisco Chronicle and
there was announcement that a large bank
was going to close 125 branches and so I
wrote them a letter and pretty soon I
was talking to these these all guys
called the Rat Patrol that was the
retail action team and they called
themselves the Rat Patrol they were
overseeing the closing of 125 branches
and and so the interesting thing was to
get to know me they sent me out and they
said well we'll send you two for good
closings and for bad closings and to try
to figure out the difference between
what's happening in the in the closings
and the difference was actually pretty
clear which was that in the good
closings in every case they the branch
manager would talk about how they were
ignoring the procedures from the Rat
Patrol and I still remember I was in San
Jose as a branch manager and he holds up
like this big book from the Rat Patrol
and he said the secret to my success is
I ignored everything in this book so and
then you see where this is going the bad
closings in all those cases sort of like
what's the opposite story which was you
know we tried to follow the procedures
that was so in frustration and
frustrating with words we heard over and
over again but we just couldn't do it
and by the way as a little sort of
footnote here and you can all imagine
this happening I was a young assistant
professor I was probably 32 or so then
and I guess I was naive enough to come
in and tell them the truth and sort of
give him a headline sort of like I just
gave you so there's five people in the
room and within like two minutes they
all left except for like the most junior
guy who escorted me the elevator and I
never saw them again but any oh also I
gave a talk at the Commonwealth Club I
should add this I gave a talk at the
Commonwealth Club and a guy came up to
me afterwards and he walked up to me he
said so this is just this serious like
twenty something years later and he said
I was on the Rat Patrol and I said oh no
he's gonna go after me and he said that
was the most screwed up team was
everyone in my life so I got a little
new confirmation anyway one other
example and I can't resist this this is
not in the book I just got permission
from Ed Catmull to use it so I've been
lucky that in addition doing some
interviews I've done some variation of
this talk two or three times at Pixar
this year I can't even remember it I
love Pixar it's like my favorite
organization in all dimensions and
except for maybe I do I might even love
them more but so so this spiritual head
and the CEO and the person who was
driving a cultural force behind Pixar as
IDI Catmull that's him and he's sitting
next to a guy there named Alvy Ray Smith
and and Pixar has such a long twisted
history I can't even begin to touch the
details here but there was one point in
Pixar's
history where they were part of the
George Lucas Empire and and there was a
point where and some of you may know
that Steve Jobs bought it for something
like five million dollars in part
because George Lucas was going through
an expensive divorce and needed the
money and jobs kept saying I'll give you
five million dollars he kept saying no
no no and finally he got it
but this was during the period that they
were prettying up what actually became
Pixar it wasn't even called Pixar then
for sales and also they were trying to
cut costs in the Lucas Empire and there
was an efficiency expert type guy who
George Lucas hired who kept pressing
Edie Catmull and that's Alvy Ray Smith
next to him the guy who invented what
basically made made modern digital
movies possible anyhow so modern digital
animated movies possible and they kept
getting our all this pressure to give
this guy a layoff list so every morning
they come in and say where's the last
list where's the layoff list and finally
it was we have to have the layoff list
by tomorrow morning or it's kind of like
all over we're gonna shut the whole
thing down so what happened was that
Alby Ray Smith and Ed Catmull gave him a
list with two names on it
Edie Catmull and Alvy Ray Smith and
that's that case it's one of those
interesting little stories that every
time I go to Pixar and give a talk one
of the old-timers comes up to me and
tells me that story because it's one of
the reasons that Edie is so well loved
is he they feel like Ed's got their
backs and and one thing I would really
emphasize it
I got approval to use this from Ed
Catmull and he said I don't want to
leave the impression that layoffs are is
a bad idea sometimes they are necessary
but he said that was a bad business
decision so that's why we fought so hard
so one really emphasized it ed catmull
it sort of insisted I add that okay to
parting thoughts and hopefully we can
have some time for some conversation
quickly because this one is a pretty
quick one although it's not fair to pick
one magical question to figure out
whether you're a good boss or in fact a
good team member if I was gonna pick one
there was some cool research that's
being done by a guy named Rob Krauss at
University of Virginia he's done this in
more than 50 companies and he keeps
finding the best predictor of whether or
not somebody is in a network of
innovative people whether or not
individuals are promoted whether or not
they stay in an organization is the
simple question he asks which is of the
people in their social network after you
talk to this person
do you have more or less energy and I
think it's a pretty cool question and
you might want to think of the boxes
you've were
with in the effects that you have on
others and one other thing I would
emphasize is this is not an argument for
charisma or being exciting what Rob
crass talks about is the people who tend
to be Energizer's are actually people
who others sort of trust and make them
feel more confident not necessarily sort
of like a razzle dazzle sort of person
or in the second one which which I'm
doing at the Alumni folks request is is
sort of to go back to the no
rule and to just offer you some thoughts
well I hope not very many of you have
lousy bosses and I won't ask is is some
ideas about dealing with lousy bosses
let's sort of like switch gears and go
back to the no rule and I and
and so in putting together sort of a
short guy this is kind of what I came up
with the first thing is if you can get
out get out if you possibly can all the
research is really if it's bad in some
of us are in situations for personal
reasons
for financial reasons where you just
can't get out for now so I understand
that but the evidence really is if
you've got a lousy boss that they're
going to do damage so that's my first
sort of diagnostic questions the other
one is to think about what kind of lousy
boss you've got if they're merely
incompetent maybe you can wait a little
bit longer because I mean some of it
might rub off on you but the evidence
incompetent bosses especially the nice
ones are kind of weird actually of like
a nice and competent boss and you kind
of feel bad so so um you could you can
wait a while longer they're unlikely to
do much damage to you if you've got
somebody who is an the evidence
actually is pretty clear that that the
the moderate damage they can do to your
physical and mental health is bad enough
that I would say turn up the volume and
running for the exits and then finally
if you've got the double whammy well to
me that's a sign you better really run
for that set so those are sort of my
diagnostic questions in to me there's
three basic strategies one is there
might be some situations and this is
where you've really got to do the
calculation to give the boss the direct
negative feedback so it it by the way
and this is something I talk about in
good boss bad boss
there's a lot of evidence that we human
beings are quite unaware of our
weaknesses but we're incredibly blind to
it in fact if you look at the research
the two groups of people are going to be
your bosses especially unaware are
either really overbearing bosses well
they're kind of a problem and also
there's this it's great and scary
research called unskilled and unaware of
it it turns out that the more
incompetent that people are to tasks the
more they overestimate their skills so
so so you've got to consider the
possibility that your boss might
actually just be unaware of his or her
weaknesses and maybe you could pull them
aside and have like a polite but frank
conversation and you got to do that
calculation the other thing is fighting
and biting back in public in general I
don't recommend this and I've done it in
my life and I've been sorry to them to
tell you the truth several times but
there it might reach a point where you
feel like that's the only thing you can
do to defend your honor and in fact
where I got this from initially so even
before the no rule was published
I was actually interviewed by Ron Reagan
Ronald Reagan's son and it was he's a I
didn't know she's a radio host or at
least used to be in Seattle and so he
described when he was a dancer that when
he would get like abused a little bit
too much in public
he'd have to fight back to the creative
director because to show him that he was
tough enough not to be pushed around the
other thing I would add and this is
something you'll see from me
again is that to the extent you can do
this in a posse you can do this with
others you're probably safer than doing
it yourself and and and you've also got
to do sort of like the little risk
analysis here which is how much risk am
I willing to take if they blow up on me
and what's the likelihood of the
person's personality so that's one the
next one is to sort of sneak around them
and again you got to sort of do the
political calculation so using the
system so the first thing here every HR
person every attorney will tell you the
more closely you can document it the
better shape you're in for all sorts of
reasons and so and again I would ask you
got to do the political calculation
which is how much power does your boss
have how do you think he or she is going
respond to criticism cuz there's there's
the boss is all-powerful if it's well if
it's Steve Jobs at Apple your odds
probably aren't too good at winning I
would just pick one example I think is
safe and once again and and we've now
got a couple of peer-reviewed research
articles that back this up that to the
extent you can do it with others you
will be in a more powerful position and
one of my favorite stories this was
actually a government employee an animal
control officer and she wrote me the
sort of detailed sort of set of emails
where she explained and it sort of asked
the saga unfolded that they had an
boss but what they did first
initially was she went and complained to
the boss's boss about about this
difficult person and it was like this is
a civil service job you'll never get rid
of was actually her and but what she did
was she got together with her coworkers
and they put together what she called
the Diaries and and what they
did was they had all this documentation
they brought it to the boss's boss and
actually they did get rid of this person
and this is consistent with some
peer-reviewed research and we're at 7:30
so I'm going to go through this one sort
of quickly the other strategy which is
probably not great in the long term but
in the short term sometimes we all get
in situations we've got to endure that
lousy boss and there's a bunch of things
that seem to work here to join or form a
support group I won't name the school
but there's one school I know that it's
not Stanford where they had a Dean who
the staff hated this is a true story and
what they did was they formed a prayer
group these were the assistants where
they would pray that something would
happen to the Dean that was bad enough
he had to quit but not so bad it was
really like life threatening or anything
like that
so I thought was so interesting the
other thing is to find some way to limit
contact with the person as much as
possible to sort of view the person as a
toxin so that's one strategy that I've
heard that's one of the great things
about email and it may be even from a
phone call so you actually can be pretty
obnoxious but that's one of the great
things about communication technologies
look for small victories there is a
bunch of evidence where people have
feelings of control that they have
little victories
probably the stupidest one that I in the
process of writing to know rule
I heard about was a woman and this is
one of those weird food things she had a
boss who kept stealing food off her desk
and and this is like the classic sort of
power thing so what she did was she made
candies out of X lakhs and and after he
ate them she told him what happened and
anyhow so she said it was the sort of
great victory that she got but she said
he was still a jerk after that reframe
the situation just in the name of time
I'm not going to tell you the whole
story we can talk about it later but in
these two the basic message and this is
one of the things that I actually tell
new assistant professors sometimes at
Stanford is if there's all the stuff
going around and there's always stuff to
get upset about but what really matters
is writing n numbers of peer-reviewed
articles so we can keep you around and
that's pretty you know are so there's
other things in our system but that's
number one and it's this ability to
practice the fine art of emotional
detachment because sometimes there are
things in life where you can't control
it you can't stop it and you kind of got
to get through it and becoming a little
bit more emotionally detached not
letting it touch your soul as sometimes
the best we can do and it's something I
frankly am NOT very good at doing
because I'm one of those sort of like
overly emotional personal probably cares
too much about things and responds too
strongly but even it like in my 50s I've
sort of learned to do a little bit of
emotional detachment rather than just
and I think that it does help with our
physical and mental health at least in
the short term okay so I'm a little bit
over do we have time for a few questions
are we okay okay so so why don't we
declare the official whatever prepared
remarks over and I hope you have some
comments or questions and they've asked
that you use the microphones is that
correct yes
for the recording okay so hopefully
somebody has some comments or questions
I and I'd love to hear some and escape
if you have to it's late
see who's looking for the microphone
who's going oh great okay so actually so
when you look at obviously you know a
good boss or bad boss how do you
evaluate that ahead of time where you
say you know the bad thing if you're a
bad boss you have to exit but you know
you obviously you want to try to avoid
entering into something like that and
you know in a job interview or anything
like that you know what is what is they
as a diagnostic or tools what he used to
say is this person can be a good boss or
they can be about so so my perspective
well you know there's all sorts of ways
to do intelligence on firms there's
things like Glassdoor like if you look
at HP at Glassdoor versus for example
Facebook or Apple there's huge
differences so you get some hints at the
company level but that's not a very good
predictor of the boss and the thing I
always say is in the interview it's hard
to tell sometimes you might want to look
if they won't let you let you get in a
word edgewise if everybody on the boss
seems sort of terrified of the person
you can look for those little diagnostic
signs but the best thing you can do and
I always say this and it's not always
possible but sometimes it is is to find
somebody who used to work for the person
because that's where you tend to get the
truth and and and this is where I would
say that having gossip networks are
actually pretty effective but but and my
wife had some great experiences where
she almost worked for flaming
until she found out the truth and and so
so that's number one on the list if you
can get it but looking for the little
signs and interviews might might help
I'm gonna go to this side I'm gonna be
Democratic or fair yes I left a job
where I had all sorts of bad boss
situations but one of the one of the
advice that my attorney gave me was
don't talk to HR at all uh-huh so and
that's Kim that's a little bit different
than what you know sorry you're not the
first person to tell me this as a chair
works for the man okay so I thought I
would listen to this advice and there
are some organizations where it isn't
true it but there's enough of them where
it isn't that I appreciate you bringing
up that perspective so thank you
fellow over here actually to two parts
first part what is Ruth
seyton cesspool Mataji oh the second
part is what about servant leadership
servant leadership so I always well
let's ask people always talking about
servant leadership I sort of ready why
don't you define what it is because go
ahead well to me a servant leader son
who does put all his people underneath
him above in the fact that he's there to
empower them to do their best job so I
and I think that's consistent with my
message but I would still argue that
even though the sir she is putting them
above that boss still ultimately
actually does have authority over them
so there are still some of those those
differences but to the extent somebody
can see themselves as a servant
leadership and by the way somebody and I
hate to say nice things about my Dean
but I really think Jim Plummer does have
that perspective that it hasn't been
true of every Dean I've had at Stanford
but he really does have that mindset he
so I would so I would say I actually
have a servant leader boss and I can
sort of tell it but he's still the boss
so this Ruth Satan cesspool strategy
which actually wrote about in the New
York Times you can can probably find on
my blog so this is somebody I knew who
worked for just a horrible boss just
really sort of a abusive and she was in
the situation of sort of like reframing
it and getting through it and the way
she got through it was when she went to
meetings she remembered at one point she
was in this horrible meeting with a sky
that that when she was a teenager she'd
gone river rafting in the American River
and the guy taught her that um when she
fell out of the boat what she should do
is rather than fight the current
she should relax and put her legs out in
front of her and gently bump off the
boulders and in fact she fell out of the
boat this is in something that was that
was called the Satan cesspool that's
where it comes from and she put her feet
out in front of her and she said was
sort of cool she just bounced off the
the rocks and didn't fight it and then
when she got in the meetings with the
boss when he would start
attacking her she said she's sort of
half shut her eyes and put her feet out
in front of hers and have the words
bounced off her feet so sort of like
this coping and reframing strategy of it
not touching your soul so that's that's
where it where it came from
yeah first I two questions
first ones easy uh what what did the guy
at Pixar do when he invited the
troublemakers in and second are the guys
that HR was low on uh-huh this curious
about that what did he do with them and
secondly more instantly perhaps um how
much of this do you think applies to
Steve Jobs or Larry Ellison or chambers
or Zuckerberg or those guys no I well
the second one let me start a second IV
I don't really know them well enough
what I will make account about
Zuckerberg even though this is being
recorded which is I don't know
Zuckerberg at all I've met him once and
you know I don't know the extent to
which the movie is fiction or not I do
have to give him credit for bringing the
entire company to the movie the day it
came out you know this they rented all
this set but but I do know some members
of Zuckerberg steam in independently of
his quality since I don't really know
Zuckerberg
it's amazing the degree to which the
people on this team have the ability to
create like what I would describe as a
full sort of civilized human being
basically so I know the head of HR
there's a guy Stanford grad symbolic
systems named Chris Cox who is sort of
the Energizer Bunny of the place so
that's the other advice I give and I'm
being very careful cuz I don't really
know the facts about Zuckerberg I don't
know him well enough is it if you're
gonna be an boss surround
yourself with wonderful people that can
offset the negative effects what was
your other question
Pixar when the new camera came in so
what Brad Bird did was he started
pushing them especially the people in IT
2 to make things look more realistic and
to use more computing power than they
ever thought was possible for a meeting
in fact where I heard about Brad Bird
was just a faculty member Margit Brando
in our department her brother Greg
Brando was the CIO and Brad came in and
they butted heads a lot but between them
it was actually quite constructive head
butting and if you watch The Incredibles
compared to the three movies before it
the water and the hair is incredibly
good at a level that nobody had Pixar
thought was possible until the black
sheep started pushing so it was
constructive conflict it wasn't I hate
you it was we're gonna do this no we
can't do it yeah we can do it it was it
was that sort of tension fell over here
so for those of us who work at global
companies or you know with offices in
other countries can you comment on the
applicability of your research across
cultures you know in the u.s. well so I
mean I don't I think I think that at the
most abstract level
mushiya poor in particular we've done a
lot of work with a Singapore a group of
us at the d.school in the last year that
there are some cultural differences
certainly the notion of for example
constructive conflict is something that
does not work very well and sometimes in
Asian cultures although one thing we
figured out and there's also I doz
experience is is that when you remove
all the bosses from the room and have
all peers actually at least some Korean
and Singaporean companies we work with
are actually pretty good so it's the
authority that creates the problem but
but at an abstract level at least in
every culture I've ever worked with in
my life the boss that people want is
somebody who is both benevolent and
competent and I think that works across
human societies but the way that it
plays out varies from culture to culture
and and in particular I think the the
openness of conflict and disagreement I
think is something you really have to be
culturally sensitive to but that applies
to companies to their some companies
where you yell at people pretty directly
and like in towel you know constructive
conflict and there's others like old HP
where they were so polite you couldn't
even tell they were fighting unless you
were an insider so you get that in US
companies but yeah that's not a fair
answer but certainly the global stuff
does make a difference okay so when do
we end because I don't want to leave so
maybe why don't we do you three and
declare victory is that fair okay okay
but and we'll do them quick okay so you
talked a lot about
what about kind of managing people that
are in the middle and you just feel will
always be kind of in the middle and you
don't see you know they're nice they get
some stuff done but you just don't see
that a so so it's people who are just
moderately confident but are not great
yeah and they're not making anyone worse
but they're not well I mean potential to
do great things well well my perspective
if it's the classic B players thing it
research on B players is actually pretty
interesting which is that although
people sometimes will complain and say I
want only a players that very often are
the people who make the organization
work on a day to day basis so they
actually can be very important and so I
would not dismiss them so quickly and
and even like the research on a players
often shows that they leave so quickly
and they have such short term time
perspectives of the a players often
aren't as hot as you think that they are
so I'm always a little bit skeptical
about about you know saying oh well
they're just they're just B players on
the other hand one thing especially
around here some of the best
organizations I know the definition of
the people who are okay in the middle
will be people who have the same
intolerance for mediocrity as the a
players but they just can't give as much
so I'm not making an argument for
mediocrity odd but but the people who
are just sort of middle performers are
actually very important but but the
people who are allows er different okay
quick we gotta go quick alright so I
don't know if I'm a good boss or a bad
boss but I'm pretty certain I've been a
bad boss okay but and what do you have
to say on recovery strategies for bad
bosses on way on recovery stress oh so
so I the recovery threat so one thing
this is actually a great question
there's actually a lot of evidence that
that despite the warned versus made it
actually is something that you need to
learn to do it's like management it's
not something that people are
necessarily born with and in fact if you
look at what great companies do and I
think I hate to go back to the old HP
but they did this for years they would
not throw people in a position where
they had an enormous amount of
responsibility in fact I work with two
former senior HP executives and they
both will tell you we started out with
one subordinate so we can only mess up
one person and and then what they would
do is actually coach people along the
way and and and I do think in our is
sort of the startup land we live in
often there isn't really time to like
deal with those details and a lot of the
people around here I think learned by
fire and a lot of people I know who will
tell you they weren't very good bosses
we're in their 20s that they sort of
learn eventually
the process so I so my short answer is
to learn by doing situation and
sometimes it happens one at a time and
the best companies put some structure
around it and even like I I know that
this is something both Apple and Google
are trying to figure out of how to sort
of develop people not just to sort of
like throw them in there and hope that
they they can do the job so so the last
thing I would say is that either you're
good or you're bad or you're out there's
actually developmental stuff okay you
got the last question okay I have a
question about the peer review process
are the review process in general it
seems like I miss my work experiences
you're involved in a unilateral review
process where your boss really is the
one reviewing you I had the fortitude of
working for an organization that adopted
the 360 review process which would seem
to be very effective and then I had
worked in an organization where they had
decided before Memorial Committee
because the organization was
extraordinary toxic the environment
toxic and when we proposed the idea of a
360 review process they took it off the
table immediately uh-huh so I guess the
question is what has the trend been in
terms of formulating a peer review
process a 360 review process and how
effective has it been in changing so the
research on peer review in 360 and
actually would separate them a little
bit because there are a few
organizations I know that will put more
weight on peer review than anything else
in fact in the the good old days at IDEO
they used to have a peer review process
where you'd pick two people to do your
review and that was it and they'd always
say that that's when the toughest
reviews happened so so that peers can
actually be quite tough but so but the
research on peer reviews there's a woman
a woman or 360 review reviews women
Jenny Chapman at Berkeley did some
research is there fine to do and they
work quite effectively but the one
disease you've got to watch out for and
this is a problem that HR can sometimes
create is that they can become so
burdensome and so time-consuming
that you end up spending like in one
organization and working with they
claimed they were spending a month a
year on their peer review process so
that's that's my main sort of concern
about 360s I think that it's
conceptually right but the challenge is
to make it in such a way that it doesn't
take too much time and/or energy because
in some organizations just one I'm
thinking of in particular became like
standardized testing for my kids
where they seem to spend all their time
preparing for and taking the test and
not actually doing learning anything and
so you got to be careful of that analogy
but when they're done lightly they're
actually quite effective so I guess and
maybe we should sort of like end on that
okay so so it's quite late as it is so
thank you very much for showing up and
sticking around my crusade it thank you
you